Batman Robin and the Joker flash drives
and a recipe for meatball cupcakes it's
episode 8 of woo let's begin with pranks
you can send someone a cow fart in a jar
a sheep brain some underwear for studs
or stick a puck in their toilet tank so
it always looks like it's full of pee
but to go high-tech try think geek spy
keylogger witch Sara tisha Slee records
everything your target types and the
Phantom keystroke are v2 when plugged in
turns on capslock glitches out the mouse
and/or spews random letters from the
keyboard this micro spy is a universal
remote that can control almost any TV
now hide your secrets and their outlet
disguised safe or just stash it in a
peanut butter and jelly pouch or a hot
dog or make your keys in the shape of a
handgun tell the difference between them
with monkeys duck keys or do keys then
cool down with this mold that makes ice
cubes straws or warm up with a sweet
toaster that burns shapes and text into
your bread handle the hot toast while
getting attacked by a shark and if
you're still not warm enough go to bed
with a hot water bottle shaped like a
urine stain pac-man ms pac-man
prefer brutal knitting we'll name a
price and this artist might make you
headgear just like grandma used to knit
not pretty enough well here's a funnel
shaped like a lily and a spoon shaped
like a giant tongue this couch is
spilling its guts it's not for sale but
you can buy this pig couch or skin a pig
and wear it as a bacon scarf Duff Beer
energy drink sonic energy drink and
unicorn poop these blood stain Nikes
will be available for Halloween and also
coming this fall Hot Wheels cars with
built-in cameras that record their
journey or can be strapped to your
helmet oh and this necklace holds an
actual living potted plant be sure to
show some love with heart-shaped eggs or
split some tunes with the heart splitter
you can also just wear this equation
that when graphed
like this want something bigger here's a
skateboard powered by an electric motor
but now it's time for something free Oh
Ryder is a distraction-free tool for
writing you can ditch the harsh word
processor for pleasing relaxing full
screen experience that makes it tougher
to be distracted now it's time for
something that I bought this week it's
kind of silly but I got a thermal
thermometer this thing's a laser pointer
that tells you the temperature exactly
and in real time of the surface it's
pointing at so for instance this coffee
is kind of cooling down but I can give
it a little laser gunpoint treatment and
tell you that it's 101.3 I can also do
things like check out my chest hair
alright chest hair clocking in at eighty
nine point eight that's nice chest hair
but the question everyone writes in
about Michael how hot is your beard well
guess what I can now give you
quantitative results my beard is ninety
point four you're welcome and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]